hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
bruh Beck I'm foreign ago and today we
have tons of info to talk about in terms
of ranked mode rewards all that good
stuff the new season 7 when that's
coming all that good stuff like that and
the executions that just released which
I made a video in which we'll get into
later and a bunch of other news coming
next week so as always like the V if you
do enjoy subscriber for new I cover the
informational side a foreigner that
think balance changes hero updates new
event patches all that good stuff the
news and the future updates and all that
stuff so let's get started with today's
video real quick before we start on top
of me reviving my Twitter I also started
a discord server so if you do want to
join that go ahead links will be in the
description for both of those and in all
future videos and on top of that about
20 minutes after this will go live I
will be streaming and I plan on not
stopping until I hit rep 50 but
gladiator so come by chill out we're
gonna be showing off some of the new
executions for some of the characters
and then all that good stuff so
hopefully come by if you want to show up
but for the news today new executions
were released in for on or today these
are the season 7 executions and they're
for every hero in the game and they cost
7,000 steel which you've probably no
doubt already seen already but if you
haven't clicked the I on the top right
and you'll be taken to my video where I
show off all the season 7 executions and
judging from the video it looks like
Centurions berserkers wardens and
Highlanders executions can ledge the
opponent which is really cool if you
play those characters sadly most of the
info including Valcke and warden reworks
new map patch notes an unannounced
marching fire stuff which was probably
the unlimited PvE mode and a bunch of
other things they haven't mentioned will
be in next week's stream so sadly we
have to wait another week for that info
but stay tuned on the channel with
notifications on to stay up to date with
all the fall on our news and I'll keep
you guys up to date and on top of that
foreigner will also be free for the half
of the month on xbox if you're familiar
with what games of gold is the feature
on xbox that's basically what it is
foreigner will be free for somewhere in
August and if you download it you keep
it for free so we're gonna be seeing a
lot more new players on xbox for those
players like myself but getting into the
juicy bit of today the new season 7 name
is going to be called storm and fury
with a very similar background with a
blue tint ranked mode will finally be
having the master and Grand Master ranks
which is higher than diamond 5 the ranks
will have a leaderboard to see who is
the best and of the best in for honor
the master rank is going to be the top
1% of players after diamond 5 and Grand
Master is going to represent the top 100
players in the world
on top of that duel is now separate from
tournament mode meaning you don't have
to sit for an entire hour to play a
tournament for duel and I simply play
one person win or lose then fight
another person tournaments will only be
available on the weekends for now but
that could change depending on what we
say and on the weekdays it will be the
example from before where it's just one
game win or lose then afterwards queue
for another fight without waiting an
hour only one of these will be present
at a time as to not split the player
base and rank Dominion is now removed
from the game because no one really
played it and now there will be unranked
tournament events as well for some
testing purposes like some to be twos
and stuff like that but the rinks are
cool but there's really no incentive to
play to get that rank but all the
previous season tournament rewards are
back in the game so if you wanted an old
ornament color and stuff like that from
season 2 3 4 all that good stuff they
will be in the game permanently and
they're guaranteed rewards at any level
even if you win or lose if you win in
season 7 you get every single tier in
the game that being the ornament the
color swatches and emblem for the
character you played stuff like that
here's an example on-screen of what I
mean this is only for tournament mode
and not the normal dual ranked games
here are the rewards for every hero in
the season 7 in terms of ornament
rewards and then also next up is going
to be the engravings for the season 7
tournament rewards also after every
regular ranked duel game you win you
will also have a chance to win the
tournament rewards I showed you in the
previous ones from the past seasons so
lots of a ways to achieve the new
tournament loot to recap the regular
duel games which is just they want to be
one you play them you win or lose then
you go back to the next person you earn
the rewards only if you win and it's
also a percentage so even if you win you
may not get a reward anyway but for the
tournament rewards you're guaranteed a
reward regardless if you make it to the
semis or the finals but the more of the
higher you climb the more items you will
receive there's also going to be some
ranked event orders as well and there's
going to be some new participation
rewards for those event orders that
being ranked or unranked regardless of
what it is which is even if the order is
complete you could still contribute to
that and still get rewards but like I
said even if it's fully done this is
mostly because some of the orders in the
game are really easy and people finish
those within 3 hours and then the people
that work 9 to 5s or some long night
shifts and stuff like that can't really
attempt these before it was even
finished so yeah let me know what you
guys think let me know if you're excited
for the executions also let me know if
you think this is going to get people to
come back into the ranked mode I hope it
because ranked is actually a really fun
mode just no one plays it which really
sucks as I said the Valkyrie and warden
reworks the new map patch notes an
unannounced marching fire stuff which
I'm like I said is probably going to be
the PvE mode they haven't really talked
about it's going to be mentioned in next
week's stream which is the exact day
that season 7 releases so don't worry I
will keep you all up to date so as
always keep the notifications on and
stuff like that but yeah it's going to
be the end of the video today guys
hopefully guys didn't enjoy it like the
V if you did enjoy its discover for new
I covered the informational side of
foreigner that being balance changes
hero updates patch notes new event
orders all that good stuff but that my
two most recent videos will be on screen
if you guys want to check that out when
that guys over here yesterday take part
of the video and peace out I'll see you
in the livestream
[Music]
you
[Music]